bear grylls as a show yeah and he on the
show you wrestled an alligator yeah so
so went on the show running wild with
Bear Grylls last offseason went down to
Panama and we went out in the jungle and
just kind of survived for two days and
at one point we're doing walking through
this dry creek bed and he had been
talking about hey we need to find dinner
it's starting to get late find a
campsite and that kind of thing
make fire eat and we come around the
corner and there's a six-foot alligator
and he said alright that's dinner I said
alright well how do you propose we do
this he said well I'm gonna distract it
you jump on it stab it kill it got it
carry it we did it and did you eat the
alligator oh yeah yeah listen we
everything you saw and it was was
exactly what happened he kind of
distracted it with a kind of formed a
noose out of this paracord that he had
and kind of hooked its upper jaws so
that it couldn't wheel around and bite
my face off when I jumped on it and I
jumped on it pushed it's pushed its
snout down and then stabbed it killed it
we flipped it over we gutted it and I
carried it about a mile to the campsite
and we made a fire cut steaks out of his
tail
put him on a stick just like roasting a
marshmallow way that you and I are
different
there are a couple you're an amazing
athlete great football player I would no
more ever do that in a million years I
would not know how to do that could you
do that Andy could you wrestle him then
no I wouldn't do that I mean I need
alligator but it'd be in a restaurant ya
know like deep-fried yeah well no but I
mean no and I've had alligator before in
Louisiana you know they have it on the
menu but no I wouldn't I wouldn't kill
it you know no it would have had to have
messed with me first
yeah it would have to be a like a worse
thing yeah yeah like you got threatening
letters for it right right
pursuing me or something